الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا قال سنوجه قوه
باتجاه البحر الاحمر اي تدخل فاننا لن
نتوانى عن تاديبه وهذا خيار احنا اخترناه
ولا يمكن ان نتراجع عنه وسنقاتل الى يوم
القيامه ولو ما يبكي مننا من يخب نفذت
القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
عمليه عسكريه النوعيه استهدفت سفينه
تجاريه امريكيه كول وذلك بعده صواريخ
بحريه مناسبه ان هذه العمليه تاتي بعد
ساعات فقط من استهداف القوات البحريه
بالقوات المسلحه اليمنيه للمدمره
الامريكيه يو اس اس رفلي بعده صواريخ
بحريه في البحر الاحمر وكانت الاصابه
مباشره ودقيقه بفضل الله حكومه صنعاء
تتحدى امريكا وبريطانيا وتضم البحر العربي
الى البحر الاحمر الاتحاد الاوروبي يجتمع
للرد ولندن تستنجد بايران بريطانيا تدرس
الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه والجنود
المتمركزون قرب القطاع يغادرون للانتقال
الى الشمال فما الذي يجري بقدره جديده تل
ابيب تغرق انفاق الفصائل المعارضه العبريه
تهاجم النتنياهو وبشده ومدير جهاز الامن
العام العبري يلتقي برئيس المخابرات
المصري في القاهره فما السبب الخارجيه
الامريكيه تصرح اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في
حلف شمال الاطلسي وشركه التصنيع العسكري
الغربي تحتاج لعامين للحق بروسيا هنغاريا
تحدد شرط الموافقه على تمويل الاتحاد
الاوروبي لاوكرانيا وموسكو تحذر واشنطن من
اعاده نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بريطانيا لندن تستنجد
بطهران ابو اليمن يضم البحر العربي الى
عملياته التي بداها في البحر الاحمر وكانت
مصادر يمنيه افادت ب اطلاق الجيش اليمني
عددا من الطائرات المسيره الاستطلاعيه نحو
خالج عدن وبحر العرب وقالت المصادر ان هذه
المسيرات تعمل على رصد اهداف بحريه جديده
من اجل استهدافها مشيره الى وجود
استعدادات لعناصر الجيش بمشاركه خبراء
ايرانيين لنقل صواريخ مجنحه وبحريه الى
مدينتي البيضاء وتعز بهدف زياده وتيره
الهجمات على السفن في المنطقه واليكم
المصدر وبالتالي الحوثيون يقومون باطلاق
الصوارخ من مناطق سيطرتهم من البيضاء
ومحافظ تعز وهي مناطق جبليه تطل ايضا
لكنها لا تقع ليس لديها شريط ساحلي في بحر
العرب او خليج عدن وقال وزير دفاع صنعاء
اللواء الركن محمد ناصر العاطفي ان بلاده
مستعده لمواجهه طويله مع الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا مضيفا نقول لهم من البحر الاحمر
نحن من يضع الخاتمه المؤلمه للهيمنه
الامريكيه التي تكتب نهايتها بيديها مشيرا
الى ان زعيم حكومه صنعاء عبد الملك الحوثي
يدرك طبيعه التحديات والعواقب التبعه من
اغلاق البحرين الاحمر والعربي امام تلبيب
فيما كان وزير الدفاع البريطاني جراند
شابس قد استنجد بايران ل يحثها على
استخدام نفوذها على اليمنيين وفصائل مسلحه
اخرى بالمنطقه لخفض التصعيد وذلك عبر
حسابه على منصه اكس وهنا يتحدث المصدر في
البحر الاحمر حث وزير الدفاع البريطاني
الجانب الايراني على استخدام نفوذه على
الحوثيين وفصائل مسلحه اخرى بالمنطقه لخفض
التصعيد وقالت وسائل اعلام ان وزراء دفاع
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجتمعون في فرنسا لمناقشه عمليه عسكريه
اوروبيه مشتركه في البحر الاحمر وبعوده
الى القطاع قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
لا يوجد طرف بمقدوره توفير المساعدات في
غزه بقدر ما تفعل الاونور ونريد ان يستمر
هذا العمل وبشان العدل الدولي قالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان امريكا تتوقع من تل
ابيب ان تحدد ما تحتاجه للالتزام بقرار
محكمه العدل الدوليه مضيفه انه ينبغي
تنفيذ العمليات العبريه في اطار التزام
الكامل بالقانون الانساني الدولي وكان
وزير الخارجيه العبري يسرائيل كاتس ان
العمليه العسكريه العبريه ستستمر حتى في
حال الافراج عن جميع الرهائن المحتجزين
لدى الفصائل بينما افادت شبكه سي ان ان ان
المخابرات المصريه سلمت الفصائل اقتراحا
اوليا لاطلاق سراح رهائن وتم التوصل اليه
خلال المفاوضات التي ضمت مصر وتل ابيب
وقطر والولايات المتحده في باريس هنا افاد
موقع اكسيوس بان مدير جهاز الامن العام
العبري تين بيت رونين بار زار القاهره
والتقى برئيس المخابرات المصر عباس كامل
واضاف اكسيوس ان بار ناقش امكانيه قيام
الجيش العبري بتوسيع عمليته الى مدينه رفح
وشملت مباحثات الطرفين الوضع على طول ممر
فيلادلفيا وفي الداخل العبري اتهم زعيم
المعارضه يائير لابيد رئيس الحكومه
النتنياهو بعدم الاكتراث للاضرار التي
سببها المؤتمر الداعي لعوده الاستيطان الى
القطاع ومشاركه وزراء واعضاء كناس من حزب
الليكود الحاكم في المؤتمر وقال بيد ان كل
ما يكترث له نتنياهو هو البقاء في سده
الحكم حتى لو احترقت التلبيب حسب تعبيره
مضيفا انه ليس مؤهلا لقياده الدوله وانه
حان الوقت لاستبداله لنضع لكم المصدر من
جانبه اتهم زعيم المعارضه في اسرائيل يا
اير لابيد رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
بعدم الاكتراث للاضرار التي سببها المؤتمر
الداعي لعوده الاستيطان الى غزه لنعد الى
بريطانيا حيث اعلن وزير الخارجيه ديفيد
كاميرون لهيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه ب بي سي
ان بلاده ستنظر مع حلفائها في مساله
الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه بما في ذلك
في الامم المتحده مؤكدا ضروره اظهار تقدم
لا رجعه فيه نحو حل الدولتين للشعب
الفلسطيني وميدانيا اعترف الجيش العبري
بانه بدا في استخدام اليه اغراق الانفاق
بالمياه لتدمير شبكه انفاق الفصائل في
القطاع ووفقا للبيان يتم استخدام نظام
المضخات والانابيب ومجموعه كامله من
التطورات الهندسيه لهذه الانشطه تجدر
الاشاره الى انه ليس كل نفق او عمود مناس
لاستخدام هذه الطريقه فيما اعلن وزير
الدفاع العبري افغان ان جيش بلاده سيتحرك
قريبا في الشمال حيث تتبادل قواته القصف
يوميا مع مقاومه لبنان وقال جالانت ابلغت
الجنود المتمركزين قرب الحدود مع القطاع
انهم سيغادرون المنطقه للانتقال الى شمال
استعدادا لهذه العمليات المستقبليه وبين
هذا وذاك اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ان واشنطن لا تريد ان يتوسع الصراع في
الشرق الاوسط وحمل الرئيس الامريكي ايران
المسؤوليه عن الهجوم الذي اسفر عن مقتل
ثلاثه جنود امريكيين في الاردن قائلا ان
طهران زودت منفذي الهجوم
بالاسلحه موعد الانضمام
للنيو هدف اوكرانيا سيتحقق او هكذا تعلن
واشنطن لكن متى يجيب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن مصرحا بان
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في حلف شمال الاطلسي
الناتو دون ان يحدد موعدا زمنيا لذلك في
سياق اخر قال رئيس الوزراء الهنغار فيكتور
اوربان في مقابله مع مجله لوبوان الفرنسيه
ان الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
هو السياسي الوحيد القادر على انهاء
الصراع في اوكرانيا مضيفا انه لو كان
دونالد ترامب رئيسا للولايات المتحده في
فبراير عام 2022 لما اندلعت الحرب في
اوروبا بينما انتقد رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الاوروبيه جوزف بوريل الدعوات لمصالحه بين
روسيا واوكرانيا مشددا على ضروره حشد جهود
الغرب لزياده الدعم لكيف وتمكينها من
تحقيق الانتصار بحسب مجله لوبز الفرنسيه
هناك اعلن الامين العام لحلف الناتو
ستولتنبرغ انه يجب على الولايات المتحده
ان تستمر في مساعده اوكرانيا على تدمير
القدرات العسكريه الروسيه من اجل تعزيز
امن النيتو فيما صرح الرئيس الفرنسي
امانويل ماكرون بان الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيدرس في القمه التي ستعقد في بروكسل في
الاول من فبراير المساعده الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه لاوكرانيا الى جانب ميزانيه
الاتحاد وبحسب الرئيس الفرنسي فان هذا
يتطابق مع نهج الاتحاد الاوروبي والذي
بموجبه لا ينبغي لروسيا ان تنتصر ليعود
رئيس وزراء هنغاريا فيكتور اوربان ويقول
انه لا يمكن حل الصراع في اوكرانيا الا من
خلال التفاوض كاشفا في الوقت نفسه عن انه
مستعد لاتخاذ قرار مشترك مع دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ال 26 الاخرى بشان تمويل
اوكرانيا في القمه المقرر عقدها في الاول
من فبراير اذا تم ضمان الموافقه على
المبلغ كل عام على اساس الاجماع هنا افاد
رئيس وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
سي اي اي ويليام بيرنز بان امريكا فقدت
تفوقها في العالم الحديث بس بالنفوذ
المتزايد لروسيا والصين مؤكدا ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يستعيد الانتاج
الدفاعيه في البلاد وموسكو واثقه من
قدرتها على سحق اوكرانيا وارهاق مؤيديها
الغربيين وهنا نتصفح
المصدر بالمقابل افادت صحيفه فاينانشال
تايمز نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه بان شركه
التصنيع العسكري تحتاج عامين على الاقل
لزياده انتاج الذخيره لاوكرانيا واللاحق
بروسيا في هذا المؤشر من من جانب اخر حضر
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي ريابكوف
واشنطن من اعاده نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
في بريطانيا وقال اود ان احذر باكثر الطرق
تحديدا وحزما من هذه الخطوه المزعزع
للاستقرار مضيفا انه لن يجري تعزيز امن
المملكه المتحده ولا حتى الولايات المتحده
بهذه الخطوه ليس هناك اي تاثير تريبي
علينا
[موسيقى]
هنا
ا